mame muy buenos dias se sabe exactamente
qué fue lo que sucedió y se conoce
alguna pista del autor
sin muy buenos días desde aquí desde el
lugar de los hechos donde todo ha
comenzado a primera hora de esta mañana
entre las ocho y las ocho y media de la
mañana hora local de nueva york los
bomberos recibían una alerta varias
llamadas alertando de que salía humo de
uno de los vagones de esta estación que
veis aquí detrás de mí que ahora mismo
todavía continúa la calle cerrada cuando
han llegado al lugar de los hechos han
encontrado a varias personas heridas con
disparos de bala como decías el número
de heridos ha aumentado a 1610 de ellos
con heridas de bala y por inhalación de
humo en ese momento la policía continúa
investigando como veis detrás de mira
que está aquí se han desplazado varios
efectivos de bomberos emergencias y de
los agentes de la policía y qué sucede
hasta ahora en brooklyn cuál es el
panorama y que han dicho las autoridades
que harán a continuación
sí pues en el último parte que ha
ofrecido la ciudad sobre la situación
que aquí se está viviendo han dicho que
de momento hay un sospechoso que todavía
no ha sido localizado se trata de una
persona un hombre de complexión fuerte
que llevaría una máscara de gas con un
chaleco de color naranja y que todavía
está en búsqueda y captura como digo
este señor a primera hora de la mañana
ha comenzado a disparar en uno de los
vagones de manera indiscriminada de haya
pasado a otro vagón y las autoridades
también los investigadores también han
estado aquí trabajando desde primera
hora porque también se han encontrado
artefactos sin activar